quel est donc l'image que les
manifestations actuelles on voit de
l'industrie du camionnage on va en
parler ce soir avec catherine morneau
qui vice présidente exécutive directrice
générale du groupe morneau une société
de transport qui est bien connu au
québec dans le bas saint laurent qui
couvre l'est du canada
beaucoup de camionneurs 600 camions mis
leurs remorques voilà pour la
présentation bonsoir madame morneau
transformer ses clients on va parler
avec vous dans un instant de votre
virage électrique mais d'abord parlons
de ce qui se passe présentement ce que
vous avez vu ce que vous entendez ce
mouvement ce convoi qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
mais effectivement il ya une grande
mobilisation comme on le veut nous le
groupe mort non on ne prend pas part à
ce qu'on voit là on est on a décidé d'y
aller ou c'est avec la caution de
l'association du camionnage du québec
mais aussi parce que vous devez savoir
que vous l'avez dit que nos activités
sont principalement au canada donc on
n'est pas touché directement par contre
ce que j'en pense que dans chaque
mouvement comme ça il faut inciter au
dialogue à l'écouté de chacune des
parties puisque nous on souhaite
fortement c'est que ça se passe dans des
dents une façon sécuritaire autant pour
les gens qui y participent les gens
autour et je dirais même d'une façon
pacifique parce que déjà une lourdeur
avec tout ce qui s'est passé en société
actuellement alors je pense qu'il faut
avoir un espace de dialogue et d'écouté
dans tout ça vous dites ne pas
participer à ce mouvement là mais est ce
que vous savez s'il y a de vos camions
honneur dans votre entreprise qui
participe
pas à notre connaissance non je ne
croyais pas ok vous ne faites pas de
transport front transfrontalier mais
est-ce que vous est-ce que ça ternit
l'image de l'industrie du camionnage
je pense que ça ça lance un message
aussi de grandes mobilisations
les camionneurs ne faut savoir que
depuis deux ans le c'est pas évident on
a parlé beaucoup de un héros début de la
pandémie je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez moi mais je me disais au lieu
de se faire envoyer des fois des signes
un peu
désastreux c'était plutôt des dires ffd
pouce en l'air les gens reconnaissaient
l'industrie du transport comme un
service essentiel
mais rapidement non chauffeur depuis
avait même pas accès
par exemple à des toilettes aussi 5e
sommet qui est vraiment quelque chose de
difficile
donc il ya eu plusieurs choses qui ont
fait que ce sont fatigués des
difficultés d'accès des fois pour le
chargement déchargement toutes les
mesures le masque dans le visage les
toutes les mesures de prévention qui y
étaient deux dans le camion par exemple
donc une fatigue et possiblement qu'elle
soit c'est peut-être aussi la goutte que
pour certains en fait peut-être déborder
le vase mais il ya une accumulation je
pense et quand même 90% des camionneurs
sont adéquatement vacciner là selon les
autorités au canada faut savoir
également je pense que la population
appuie encore le travail des
travailleurs est essentielle et
camionneurs font partie du lot mais le
ton est tellement changé dans les
dernières heures et les derniers jours
autant on entend beaucoup de violence
dans le propos et les promesses de ce
qui va se passer en fin de semaine je
pense que c'est est ce que est ce que
vous le voyez comme un dérapage ou vous
pensez encore que c'est quand même
l'expression d'une exaspération
écoute et j'espère fortement qu'il
rapporte dérapage nous on dénonce toute
forme de dérapage évidemment
et j'espère que ce sera de façon comme
je vous disais pacifique et sécuritaire
j'ose espérer que ça va le faire et j'ai
confiance que les gens vont avoir cette
maturité la d'exprimer leurs propos sans
tomber dans des gestes de violence moi
j'ai confiance que que ça va se passer à
tous que je laisse pas forcément c'est
un métier difficile vous l'avez dit
depuis deux ans avec la pandémie solide
encore davantage pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre également dans votre
secteur comment vous faites pour attirer
pour garder les camionneurs et les
camionneuses également parce que de plus
en plus de femmes oui ben j'aime que
vous le mentionnez d'ailleurs une de nos
initiatives c'est présentement nous on a
des atr dont on a des écoles de
formation à l'intérieur de notre
entreprise est la dernière cordier 50%
que c'est des femmes donc c'est un peu
exceptionnel c'est la première fois
qu'on a autant de femmes évidemment on
se tourne vers beaucoup de solutions le
recrutement international qui est une
option intéressante pour nous on
travaille constamment aussi sous nos
conditions et les conditions de travail
des camions se sont beaucoup améliorés
en terme d'heures de conciliation
travail famille c'est des fois on pense
que ça nous touche moi mais au contraire
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont des
champions il ya beaucoup d'hommes ont
aussi vu qu'il ya une majorité doit
quand même dans l'industrie qui ont des
enfants aller chercher à la garderie qui
ont des responsabilités familiales puis
nous on travaille très très forte
d'avoir une gymnastique pour les aider
dans ces horaires le on essaie d'être
très présent sur le terrain parce que
les deux dernières années lyon et
éprouvante donc son manque d'écouté on
manque de présence envers nos chauffeurs
c'est sûr que ça a un impact donc on
travaille en rétention aussi pour leur
donner les mercantis et vous avez reçu
cette semaine votre premier camion
électrique un grand camion électrique
est ce que vous êtes en mode électrique
en train d'amorcer un virage électrique
va tout à fait un film nous notre
objectif c'est que d'ici 2030 on a eu au
moins 50% notre flotte qui soit
électrifié après ça peut aller plus vite
ou moins vu tout dépendamment des tests
qu'on va faire c'est notre savoir sur
notre tout premier camion alors on va
faire des tests ici dans la ville de
québec et c'était cela vont nous dire si
nos ambitions sont réalisables on le
souhaite fortement on souhaite aussi que
les coûts soient raisonnables pour qu'on
puisse être capable de faire
l'acquisition de plusieurs de ces
camions excellent on va vous suivre
merci beaucoup catherine monnot d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit